[Music]
on the dish this morning the korean
vegan joanne lee molinaro was a
high-profile trial lawyer until
transitioning to cooking videos on
youtube and tick tock where her
popularity has gone off the charts this
year the videos are one of a kind
blending deeply personal observations
with stunning food preparation inspired
by her parents struggles growing up in
north korea and her own move to a
plant-based diet now molinaro has
released her first cookbook the korean
vegan in which she mixes up many
traditional korean meals like short ribs
wings and fish stews
we sat down with her in chicago for the
full experience great cooking
and conversation
we're roasting the kochikaru we're
getting a little cook on it so what are
we making we're making sundubu which is
silken tofu stew
it is probably the first thing that my
mom ever taught me to make joanne lee
molinaro can make just about anything
you want
as long as it doesn't include any dairy
or meat you know for plant-based food
you're trying to find as many different
ways to add flavor body and depth that
you possibly can molinaro's story began
half a world away as she details in her
new book the korean vegan which includes
the emotional story of her family's
journey
several of molinaro's ancestors
including her parents were all born in
what is now known as north korea when i
first discovered that my parents were
born in quote north korea i was really
embarrassed i was very ashamed and i
don't even know why i think it just
evinces my complete ignorance
and
total lack of interest and really
understanding
my family's history or my country's
history
there was no reason for me to be ashamed
of where my parents were born but i was
so i just lied i used to tell people i
don't know my parents were born in seoul
you know molinero's parents made it to
the u.s in the mid-1970s
she went on to become a successful trial
lawyer
then five years ago she made maybe the
biggest decision of her life you went
vegan in the first place why
the most honest answer was because my
then boyfriend now husband he wanted to
go vegan and for a while i was like well
you're on your own buddy i'm not doing
that with you i can't give up my kimchi
and i'm not going to give up my progogy
on your own but there is fellowship in
eating and i was worried that if i
didn't eat the same foods that he was
eating we would lose that and so i
figured well just give it a try see what
happens like it's not going to kill you
it's the man's fault yeah yeah it's
always the man's fault molinaro started
a food blog that same year and began
posting videos the following year
they are like nothing else online ever
since i was little my mom made it very
clear to me that she was embarrassed
about certain aspects of our culture
beautifully shot demonstrations narrated
by molinero not really describing a
cooking process when non-korean friends
came over after school she would always
apologize in advance for the smell but
instead her feelings on life work and
society in general for the record i'm
done apologizing and so is my mom i
think what i'm trying to do is to create
a memorable experience
and memorable experiences are created by
some kind of emotion mine is
sentimentality nostalgia those types of
things i'm not really good at comedy
so i focus on my strengths you say at
the dinner table your family didn't
spill their guts
they filled them yeah we were very quiet
during dinner it's basically the only
sounds you heard were the ones that i
described like slurping
and like clink clink clink you know with
those chopsticks and stuff sometimes i
would actually bring like a book
or have my homework like on the table
with me while i was eating they say that
time heals all wounds they're lying some
wounds will never ever heal in the last
year molinero has picked up nearly three
million followers on tick tock that
success has allowed her to transition
away from legal work to focus on cooking
almost full time
the feast she laid out for us is just a
small sample of that what you have here
is rice right okay so that's pop and
this is you know kind of my favorite mix
of rice you've got here brown rice sweet
brown rice pearl barley as well as a
little bit of black forbidden rice which
is why it comes in that lovely color and
then to the right of that you're going
to have some silken tofu stew or
sundubuchike this is the delicious spicy
stew that you helped me to make
and then we've got here mushroom kirby
got here braised tofu cucumber kimchi
chapchae
kiran mari which is a korean style
omelette some kale with some fermented
soy bean dressing we've got here some
soy glazed potatoes and then some
pickled perilla leaf obviously pichu
kimchi and then some perilla leaf
focaccia
so what do we do first you know you
really can eat whatever it's like mix in
like yeah go wherever i mean that's the
thing i love about do i bring this into
the right or like you can my husband
just like scoops it into the rice okay
um i like it separate because i like to
enjoy all the flavors on their own but a
lot of people eat it just the way you
described
delicious oh good molinero has quickly
become one of the world's most zealous
advocates for a plant-based diet
insisting not only that it's healthier
and more sustainable than eating dairy
and meats but also they can be just as
flavorful i mean the thing here is that
like
there's no meat
but
stuff tastes meaty
[Laughter]
right yeah there's a heartiness to
korean food that i think
even i when i first went vegan i was
like well then i guess i just have to
eat salads all the time you know that's
what i thought no this is like there's
no salad on this entire table
do you think people are getting more and
more comfortable with the idea of going
vegan absolutely
i mean i feel like every day there's
another news story about a new
plant-based product a new plant-based
restaurant or even if it means switching
out you know one meal a week with a
plant-based alternative i think that's
wonderful
where do you think the korean vegan goes
next
that's a good question jeff
i think that right now
i would love to
write more i love writing and i think
also making foods that look and taste
this amazing more accessible to people
is important to me whether that's you
know proliferating more recipes through
cookbooks or a blog or videos ultimately
the korean vegan will go wherever
compassion and empowerment leads it to
go
my first time making tofu stew it was
enjoyable it looked good we have come a
long way in 30 years it is a beautifully
written book and her videos really are
one of a kind
well